so i'm sure none of you will be
surprised to find out that the story of
jonah is one of my favorite stories
in scripture it is a story that i've
thought about for
many many years for 20 years and i've
explored also in iconography i've made a
few
versions of the icon of say of jonah in
the fish
and i also recently made an ink drawing
that i
colored and uh you know it just kind of
plunged me back into the story of jonah
and so i thought we could go over the
story of jonah
especially looking out how the story of
jonah
shows us the interesting inversions or
the flips that happen
at the edge of the world we see it very
clearly in the story of jonah
how this is related to resurrection and
how it is related to repentance as well
so we're going to look at all that
[Music]
together
[Music]
this is jonathan pedro welcome to the
symbolic world
so for those who do not know the story
of jonah i will try to recap it as fast
as i
can so jonah is a prophet he's a prophet
of god and god
calls upon him to go to nineveh
and to tell the people of nineveh that
the city is going to be destroyed
and and so jonah doesn't want to go
he doesn't want to go to nineveh and it
doesn't say in the text why he doesn't
want to go but there's a few things that
you need to understand
is that nineveh is the enemy of israel
at the time
and so if you had to name the biggest
enemy it would be the syrian empire of
which
the capital is nineveh so god is telling
jonah to go there
and tell them that god will destroy the
city
so instead of going east which is where
he would be going
if he went to nineveh jonah ends up
going west
he goes to tarshish which is related it
seems to spain and so he leaves on the
mediterranean on a boat
to go to spain going the opposite
direction
of where he's supposed to go now you
have to see it in terms of cosmic
symbolism already instead of going
east towards let's say the rising of the
sun he goes west towards the
setting of the sun and ultimately to the
dark place or the bottom
of the world the bottom of the ocean is
also related to
the west especially for people at the
time the west
would have been seen the as ultimately
the place where the ocean is where
the the great you know leviathan is the
great serpent of the
oceanis is at the edge of the world
because the western ocean was seen as
this
this massive flowing uh ocean that's on
the edge of the cosmos
and so jonah goes out and gets on a boat
and leaves now while he's on a boat
there is a storm a massive storm but
interestingly enough
jonah is asleep at the bottom of the
boat
and during that time the people in the
boat are freaking out and they're
invoking their god and they're praying
and they're like what's going on why are
the gods angry at us what have we done
to anger the gods and then they realize
that there's one character who's not
there
yet who's not with them he's asleep at
the bottom of the boat
and that is in fact jonah so they pull
jonah out and they say
why you have to invoke your god as well
because you know we need to figure out
what's going on we need if one of our
gods is angry
you know so jonah says look i don't even
have to do that i'm not going to invoke
my god anyways he doesn't want to
he says i'm the reason i'm the reason
why the storm is coming because i
disobeyed my god
and so jonah says toss me over the boat
and everything will be fine
so the foreign mariners these guys who
are not at all
israelites they don't want to do it they
don't want to throw them over the boat
that would be horrible
and so they try to find other solutions
they try to pray they do all these other
things but ultimately
they have no choice and they end up
listening to what jonah says they throw
him over the boat
and so when they throw him over the boat
jonah is
swallowed by a giant fish
and the fish takes him down into the
water water and he stays there for
three days at the end of the third day
that is when jonah has his repentance
so he goes to the bottom of the of the
ocean and he has is
this transformation so what i'm going to
do is i'm going to read for you
jonah's prayer and we'll come back to it
afterwards in terms of interpretation
but it's one of the most beautiful
texts to try to understand this flip
that happens at the bottom this flip
that happens at the end
so jonah prays he says i called out to
the lord out of my distress
and he answered me out of the belly of
death i cried and you heard my voice
for you cast me into the deep into the
heart of the seas
and the floods surrounded me all your
waves and your billows passed over me
then i said i am driven away from your
sight
yet i shall again look upon your holy
temple
the waters close in over me to take my
life
the deep surrounded me weeds were
wrapped around my head
and at the roots of the mountains i went
down to the land whose bars
closed upon me forever yet you brought
up my life from the pit o lord my god
when my life was fainting away i
remembered the lord
and my prayer came to you unto your holy
temple
those who pay regards to vain idols
forsake their hope
of of steadfast love but i with
the voice of thanksgiving giving will
sacrifice to you
what i have vowed i will pay salvation
belongs to the lord
and then god spoke to the fish and the
fish
vomited jonah onto the dry land
so of course now jonah has no choice he
goes to nineveh to warn the city that
god will destroy
but when jonah gets to nineveh and he
tells the people of the city that god
will destroy the city
the king tears his clothes and you know
puts ash on his head and does all these
penitent gestures
and tells the whole city that they need
to repent
and so the whole city uh fast it says in
the scripture even the animals fast
so the entire city fasts because of this
news
that the city is going to be destroyed
and then
jonah and then god doesn't destroy the
city
and you'd think jonah would be happy but
of course joan is not happy jonah says
i knew you would do this i knew you
would not destroy the city if they
repented
because you're a merciful god and so
he's extremely annoyed
uh and he decides to leave and goes east
of the city goes out of the city
and then he comes to a place where it's
not covered and so
he sits there and there's the wind and
the sun and he says you know what i just
want to die
i just i'm just going to die here okay
so he sits there and during the night
god makes a a plant grow
and this plant grows up kind of like a
vine and ends up acting
like a shade over his head and covers
him
from the sun and the the wind
uh and so jonah feels good about that
he's happy about to have this tree
uh but then again during the next night
he uh god god destroys the plant as well
he wakes up and the plant is dead and
now god is extremely angry and
uh jonah is extremely angry and once
again he says that's it i'm done i just
want to die
you know this is over um and then god
answers him and says so you are so
worried you're so annoyed that i
destroyed this plant
yet you would want me to destroy this
city
which has you know countless people and
animals and then he says a strange thing
about how they do not know they're left
from their right
and that is how the story ends now
there's so much in this story
i will not be able to to uh let's say go
through all the elements all the
symbolic elements i
want to draw a thread through it and uh
so so don't
don't don't call me out and tell me i
forgot some elements because i'm going
to try to remember as much as possible
try to get into as much as possible but
obviously there's a limit
and so one of the interesting things
about the text and is which was
important to understand is that it seems
very much that this
story is a comedy that everything about
it is kind of upside down
it's it's meant to be funny because
everything
jonah does is is kind of upside down and
you can we'll see it as we go through
how everything manifests itself in
in a funny upside down way but that it
this calm
this comedic aspect is related to the
turning
we've talked about this in terms of the
notion of the fool of the world of the
fool
and so this turning is related to the
comedy and we'll see how this turning
uh is going to is going to show us
what is the some aspect of the mystery
of the resurrection
and uh and repentance of course as well
now of course the first thing
that i mentioned is that right away at
the beginning
jonah decides to go the other way he
goes west instead of going east
and then he ends up on the waters and so
being on the waters and
being in the land of the foreigner from
now on he's going to face a kind of
upside down world uh but not necessarily
in a negative sense just in the sense
that
he is going to be he's going to be in it
all constantly
in a strange upside down position
compared to the people
so here he is in this boat he is of
course asleep in the boat
being asleep in the boat is already
related to death
him being down asleep at the bottom of
the boat relates
this to the ark the ark of noah which
has the animals inside the boat
his body is related to the boat the idea
of the bottom of the boat is related to
the body
you have to understand also that when
christ is also asleep in the boat
during the storm this is all connecting
to jonah
so jonah in you know for example
in the story of the flood noah is the
innocent one
and noah goes through the flood on the
ark
to survive the flood now in this case
and he goes to move away from these
strange
hybrid mixed mixture of these these
foreign tribes that have become
warrior-like that are cain's descendants
now here we have this upside-down
situation where jonah is responsible for
the flood
uh and he's the one hiding in the boat
and the foreigners are the ones who are
invoking god and trying to find the
reason
why there's a punishment on their their
boat
and so they they they jonah has to say
i'm the one responsible right
and uh toss me out inv he they tell him
to invoke his god to
get god's mercy but he says just toss me
out into the water and the people
don't want to do it they don't want to
toss them out into the waters
now you have to see this this structure
as
opposite and in kind of a mirror image
of what's going to happen
when jonah goes to the city because in
the city
he then blames the people of the city
for the disaster that's about to happen
and when god saves them jonah is angry
jonah wants god to destroy the city
whereas here he is with these foreigners
who don't even believe in god
and they don't want to destroy him who
is the cause of
the of the the suffering and so you have
to see the whole story of jonah as this
kind of this kind of interest this
strange flip that's happening
in the story um and so jonah ends up so
they finally
accept to throw jonah overboard and then
he is swallowed by this monster
which brings them down into the bottom
of the ocean
now of course he stays there for three
days this is
this is something which will be brought
back into christianity in terms of the
three days in the fish
but one thing i didn't notice when i
told you the story is that when jonah
goes to nineveh it says that it takes
him three days to cross the city and to
kind of give his message and so these
three days are the same there's a
there's a
relationship between death this
animal garment of skin that he's now
wearing so jonah is actually
wearing a garment of skin you know as
this fish which is protecting him
underwater
and the city which is also in the
ultimate let's say garment of skin
which he's going to face later so three
days down in death
in the the garmented skin of as the fish
three days
crossing the city which is also related
like i said before
when you talk about the city and the
foreign city it is related to cane
to all this imagery which comes from
before the flood
and so then jonah has his after three
days jonah finally has his moment of
repentance
and in this moment of repentance there
are powerful very
beautiful beautiful jewels in the prayer
that jonah utters
some amaze some amazing analogies which
can help us see
what is the these analogies of death
and of covering and of garments of skin
and so he says i called out to the lord
out of my distress
now we have to understand the importance
of understanding
the idea that calling out unto the lord
is also an acknowledgement of distance
so when you are far from the center that
is when you call out
unto the lord and so this is something
which happens in scripture for example
after the fall
we see that there's the there's the fall
and the descendants of cain
the murder of abel the descendants of
cain the building of the city
and as this is as they're leaving the
garden getting farther and farther away
it says
this is when men started to call unto
the lord because there's this
relationship between
distance and calling to that which is
high
it says i called out to the lord in my
distress and he answered me
so then he repeats it and he says it in
a different way for you to understand
the distress he says i called out of the
belly of death
and you heard my voice for you had cast
me into the deep so
distress death deep the heart of the
seas you know
this idea of the bottom of the ocean or
the edge the bottom of the world
and it says the flood has surrounded me
so look at all the images amazing images
which are brought together
distress death
deep flood and then he talks about these
billows that have passed over me right
so being
underground under the water
and this is related and he says i am
driven away from your sight
so here again is the distance he i am
very far away from you
from you you cannot see me but he says
i shall again look upon your holy temple
and so now he's starting to give you
images of what
the so he's at the bottom and he's
giving you all these images of the
bottom
and now he's going to start to show you
what are the images of what is above
and he says i will look upon your holy
temple so the temple
becomes an image of the place from which
the voice of god
comes or the the place from which the
voice of the his voice as calling to god
is heard okay um so he says again the
waters closed in
and took over to take my life the deep
has surrounded me right this idea of
being around of
of wrapping around the deep the fish all
of this
uh i keep repeating but there you go but
then he says ah
uh weeds were wrapped around my head at
the root
of the mountains okay so remember again
the image of the high place and the low
place
so he's descended at the bottom of the
water he is down
at the bottom of the mountain and he
talks about
uh he talks about the place where the
bars closed upon me forever and so
the bottom of the world the bottom of
the ocean
at the bottom of the mountain is also a
prison of bars and the bars are also
related to iron this idea of the city
we'll see it you know it comes back
later in time in terms of nineveh but
the city
uh what are the other images he talks
about
um okay and then then he turns away and
he says
then you brought up my life from the pit
oh lord my god when my life was fainting
away i remembered
the lord and my prayer came to you into
your holy temple
so remembering this is what i've been
telling you guys from the beginning
the relationship between the margin and
the center between the low place and the
high place
is memory if you remember god if you
remember the thing that unites you
remember the thing that unites us
together
it doesn't matter to a certain extent
how far you are
it's the it's the connection memory is
being connected to something even if
you're far away from that
so remembering god is right away being
connected to god
and so it depends on different places
for example in the story of noah
after the flood and after they've been
in the ark for very long
instead of saying jonah remembered god
it says god remembered noah
and so remembering noah and then jonah
remembering god
is this this connection you can express
it from one way or the other right you
can express it kind of bottom up as
emergence if you will
and you can express it top down as a
more hierarchical way of seeing it
and so he remembers and his prayer goes
up to the holy temple
once again i told you the the connection
of the place of god
as the holy temple imagined as something
like the garden of eden at the top of
the hill
um and so and then he talks about
he talks about those who pay regard to
vain idols forsake their hope of
steadfast
love but with the voice of thanksgiving
will sacrifice to you
what i vowed i will pay salvation
belongs to the lord
and so he talks of course about let's
say fake world of idols
but what's important to understand is
the idea of thanksgiving
because one of the things that connects
you to the center also connects you to
god
is the idea of giving thanks for that
which you have received
when you are bitter when you are when
you forget
what you have when you forget what you
have received that's when you
fall into fragmentation of death when
you remember what you have received
when you remember what how you're
connected together and you're connected
to your origin
then you have hope and you have hope of
love right hope of steadfast love and he
says what
i what i have vowed i will pay and so
he's actually saying
basically i said i would you know i i'm
supposed to go to nineveh
i haven't done what i said i would do i
will do
and then of course salvation belongs to
the lord and that is when
god speaks to the fish it's important
that he speaks to the fish
because there's this creation of the
world but it's represented in a very
beautiful upside-down way because it
says
the fish vomited jonah up onto the dry
land
and so the fish you can imagine the fish
has kind of the earth coming up above
as god speaks the fish comes up above
but then he vomits jonah over
onto the ground so the humor continues
right after
this very powerful and beautiful prayer
so there's this upside down instead of
you know instead of vomiting is it
is a kind of meaninglessness right it's
like
it's like spouting gibberish as
something which was supposed to go into
your belly to be integrated
is not integrated and is is thrown out
and is kind of thrown out as trash
so here's jonah's trash on the side of
the on the side of the ocean
outside of the sea and he decides to now
go to nineveh
so when you get to nineveh this is of
course what i mentioned before
there's a very strange thing which
happens which is that
jonah is made to be a false prophet and
this is where all the upside down thing
is
it just becomes hilarious because jonah
said you know a lot of people say
that jonah told the city to repent and
that if they repent
if they don't repent god will will
destroy the city but that's nowhere in
the text it doesn't say that
it just says tell nineveh i'm going to
destroy the city.
and so he goes and says he's going to
destroy the city they repent
and then god doesn't destroy the city so
jonah is actually made to be a false
prophet
and this is this strange upside down
thing where
in becoming a false prophet he actually
ends up saving the the city or
being what looks like a false prophet he
ends up being the one who saved the city
but also
saves the foreigner he is he is actually
saving the foreigner
by going through these weird
tipsy turvy thing now this is a little
contentious for some people but you can
understand
that there's something about that in the
story of christ
that to the jews christ appeared to them
as a false prophet and they condemned
him as a false prophet
but christ ended up saving the foreigner
ended up not just saving the foreigner
but saving the city
christ saved rome and rome is really
this image the ultimate image of the
city is of course rome i know i've
mentioned to you before
that uh there's a relationship between
romulus and kane
in have wanting to kill your brother and
then after killing your brother founding
a city
there is a direct relationship and this
is a relationship that is
until today still understood by jewish
scholars today they see rome as being
related to kane
and also to esau to the this older
brother which falls
um anyways i don't want to go too much
into that
but this is the interesting part and so
he becomes a false prophet
and then the city is saved the foreign
city is saved
and of course jonah is not happy with
that
uh he is he because he's been made of
he's been made
a joke right he's been turned into a
joke he's not happy of being turned into
a joke
and so he goes now follows
the it's really really fascinating he
actually follows the backward
movement all the way into the garden of
eden now you have to see that this is
what has been happening
all along jonah leaves the bottom of the
flood
leaves the bottom of the water is thrown
up
upside down goes into the city which
precedes the flood right cain builds the
city and the technologies which brought
about the flood
goes into the city saves the city
despite himself then moves out goes
east out of the city and goes into the
land where it says that the light is
hitting him the sun is hitting him
and the wind is blowing so he's actually
moving
towards the spirit uh
but it's all in a kind of weird ironic
and upside down way he's moving closer
to the spirit
and but he's not happy with that right
he's not happy
and so god makes uh you know god makes
this garden
for him he makes a tree grow uh
and he there he is under the shade of
the tree
so being in the shade of the tree or the
shade of the vine is not just about
being in the garden but it is mostly
about covering
and so now we have come to a little
mystery which is also hidden in the
story
which is the three coverings he just
like in the temple there are different
veils
a veil of linen and a veil of wool and a
veil of animal skins
within the temple here again we also
have the three coverings we have a
covering
of a leaf just like the fig leaf that
adam and eve put on themselves that they
were falling
then we have the covering of the city
which is the covering which comes later
as cane
falls and creates a social covering and
then at the edge of the world you have
this kind of monstrous covering which is
this kind of covering of death itself
which is represented in the tabernacle
as these strange gopher skins or these
skins that we don't know what the animal
is of
and so the structure of the different
coverings in the story of jonah
is this the coverings that are found in
the genesis story but are
also the very structure of the
tabernacle itself
all right so back to the description god
kills the tree
puts him again directly in contact with
the spirit and the sun
but he can't handle it and so he wants
to die
he's he he wants to go back down he
actually
he's in the garden he's in the presence
of god in the in the spirit and the
light
and he's like no man i want the i want
the tree
i want to die i want to go back down
into the belly of the whale
and so the whole thing is you know as in
the garden of eden god told adam and eve
if you eat this fruit you will die well
here's jonah he was
past all this he's gone all the way up
and now he actually wants to die
and so god reproves him and says you
know
and this is one of the greatest
mysteries he says i'm gonna save the
city
are you angry that about are you angry
that you that you don't even have the
garden i don't just want to save the
garden i just don't want i don't want to
just save
the high place i want to save the low
place i actually want to save the city
not just the garden and so there's a
very profound mystery and then
he says the strange thing about not
being able to tell the difference
between your right and your left hand
and i think
that this is a little more speculative
in my terms i think that
this is referring directly to the garden
of eden it's referring directly to
to the idea that there's an analogy
between the
this kind of these people that have
repented and now they
can't tell the difference between the
right and the left hand
uh and did it opposite the right and the
left hand that is
the tree of knowledge of good and evil
they can't tell the difference
and that there's a strange analogy
between that and let's say
being saved and being above the
difference between
good and evil that is at least what
seems to be
being suggested and also because god
says he's going to also save the animals
which is related
to this notion of death and the garments
of skin as well
something that i've i've talked about
quite a few times and i talked about how
you know as the mystic goes up the
mountain when i talked about moses
who sheds his garments of skin but then
when he reaches the very top
he receives them again in the the
pattern of the temple
so too god in the end says he wants to
not just
he says don't just be angry about the
tree but i want to save the city and i
want to save the animal
even the outer covering and so that is
really
uh that you can see why it's really one
of my favorite stories and like i said i
just skimmed
across the surface there's so much more
going on in that story that we could
talk about
but uh but it is definitely one of my
favorite stories
and so if you uh if you uh if you like
this story uh
go ahead and check out like i said i've
put out this image
as a print and i've also put it out on
different apparel that you can get
and and so yeah so i'm just excited and
hopefully i'll have the chance to make
another version of this carving because
it is really
not only one of my favorite stories but
also one of my favorite images
as you know everything i do here on the
symbolic world is thanks to your support
don't forget that apart from just these
videos there is also a podcast which you
can find on your
different podcast platforms there's also
a clips channel which is run by an
amazing person
and is organizing my talks in terms of
different subjects there's a facebook
group where
very lively and powerful discussion is
happening out of which is coming also a
series of articles
that you can find on my website the
symbolicworld.com
and uh i've just decided with some very
with the editor of the blog
jp marshall and also kissianwa which
you've seen
on my channel that we are going to make
a french version of the blog and we're
also going to try to
add some more french content and so we
are continuously expanding here the
symbolic world
there's a lot more in the works and so
thank you for your support and thank you
for your attention i will talk to you
very soon